what's your purpose what's your cause  what's your beliefs every single person  every single organization on the planet  knows what they do 100 percent  some know how they do it but very very  few people or organizations know why  they do what they do well as a result  the way we think the way we act the way  we communicate is from the outside in  it's obvious we go from the clearest  thing to the fuzziest thing  but the inspired leaders and the Inspire  or inspired organizations regardless of  their size regardless of their industry  all think act and communicate from the  inside out  and if you talk about what you believe  you will attract those who believe what  you believe and it's those who start  with why  that have the ability  to inspire those around them or find  others who Inspire them